hello everyone and welcome to another
fine game from round 8 of the Tata steel
India Blitz Edition it is not the record
the center of world rapid Champion
versus Shakira mamajarov and uh both of
them didn't do all that uh great in the
rapid section they uh Sixth and Seventh
Place uh and now it's the blitz section
and the mamajaro is doing uh incredibly
well uh like I said this is round eight
and out of the first seven rounds he got
five wins in two draws so zero losses
for mamidaro uh another back on the
other hand uh he got like uh all losses
he he lost five games in route 2. I'm
pretty sure it's something like this I
can check uh so I I want to trick you
guys let me just really quickly check
this yeah like uh
yeah he lost six games and Drew one uh
uh so definitely a difference in in uh
the first seven rounds uh but what
happens in this game uh could mean a lot
and my major is leading the tournament
uh going into round eight so that also
has something to do with it uh so now
you're back with the white pieces opens
with D4 we have the five Knight to F3
Knights to F6 and C3 now uh we have G6
and now Bishop to F4 again some sort of
a Queen spawn opening going for uh a
London setup with Bishop to G7 H3 we
have castles and now Ponte E3 we have C5
of strikes in the center here Bishop to
E2 and now Knight the C6 we have castles
and now Knight to D7 preparing
everything for a strike in the center
with Pawn to E5 we have Knight beta D2
Ponte E5 and D captures an E5 we have
Knight D captures and E5 Knight captures
uh uh Knight captures on E5 and now
Knight to F3 offering further trades
with Knight back to C6 and now Queen to
B3 this is nothing new uh all been
played before we have Knight today 5
attacking the queen queen A3 now
attacking the C5 pawn and the queen to
B6 defending we have Rook 8 and D1 and
Rook to d8 now defending the D5 pawn and
there is the game where B4 was played
but here we have Bishop to G5 by
nederbeck and it is now as of move 16
that we have a completely new game so F6
are pushing the bishop back yes it opens
up this diagonal but it doesn't seem
like it will matter all that much Bishop
to F4 and now Bishop to E6 uh now it's
important to keep this D5 Pawn well
defended B4 attacking the Knight with C
captures uh sorry not C 4C capture some
b4c captures and Knight to C4 attacking
the White Queen now while you could
capture uh it just gives black a past
Pawn so not really
uh and not really the best option so
Queen B3 Rook ate the C8 now all of
mamidara's pieces are fully mobilized
and knights the D4 now attacking the
bishop and the bishop is very important
here regarding that the D5 Pawn so
Bishop F7 and now H4 with Bishop to f8
uh pressuring the B4 pawn and the B5 now
advancing it and not allowing black to
capture Bishop to D6 and now Bishop
captures Queen captures and pawn to G3
with Pawn to H5 and the bishop to F3 so
nicely putting pieces on optimal Square
slowly maneuvering Queen to A3 and
mamidaro offers the queen trade and
Bishop to G2 noid says all right but
under my terms and capturing on B3 isn't
all that great if you captures captures
uh the Knight has to move somewhere and
then you go after the pawn on A7 not a
good way for black to defend it you have
to move the Rook from the C file to the
to the a file and then of course you
also have the double the a pawn the
Double B Pawn and if black for advances
you would be more than happy to trade
here so instead Queen to A5 not going
for the queen trade and now Rook F to E1
uh King the G7 with Bishop to H3
attacking the rook and The Rook to C7 we
have rooked to C1 both players now ready
to double up on the C file Rook to E7
uh we have Bishop back to G2 putting
pressure on the pawn and now Rook back
to C8 Rook to E2 with Rook e to C7 and
Rook e to C2 both players now have
doubled up on the C file Knight to D2
and this is where the fun sort of begins
now you can't really trade Rooks as the
queen on B3 is hanging you could do it
but it's not going to be great if row
captures on C7 Knight captures on B3
Rook captures and see it there's Knight
captures on C1 and now you would only
have a knight and The Rook for a queen
which is okay I'm black is not uh
White's not dead lost here but it would
be very hard to play so instead after
Knight to D2 We have Queen to D3 and now
just Rook captures on C2 Rook captures
Rook captures Queen captures the Rooks
get traded off the board and Knight to
C4 now uh we have King H2 getting the
king to a bit of a safer Square king
queen to B4 and now Queen to E2 we have
Queen to B2 again Shakira as a queen
trade and another Beck goes Bishop to F1
says sure let's trade but under my terms
and now it might not be a terrible idea
to trade Queens but Shakira decides to
keep the Queens in the game Queen B1 uh
Bishop to H3 and now Pawn to F5 with
Queen to F3 and now Queen captures an A2
another back sacrifices upon for some uh
for some counter play here uh he lost
all the games so far so you know he
might as well try something Queen F4
Queen to B2 with King to G2 and queen to
B1 now preparing Queen D4 check to trade
queens and win the game and uh you would
probably see something like King H2 here
if this was a normal game but it's not
and another back lost pretty much all
hopes uh he goes for Bishop captures on
F5 he sacrifices the bishop forces a a
capture here anything other than that
would be terrible as Knights the E6
check would just assume control for
white so G captures and not Knight
captures with check and the only way to
play this is to play King to f8 which
was not played in the game I will show
it if King to fit a white will have to
settle for something like Queen to B8
check bishop p8 and not Knights to D6
going for uh Queen capture 78 and now
Queen to G6 defends everything Knight
characters and he ate Queen captures
Queen captures on B7 and uh it's uh sort
of a draw yes black is up a piece but
white is up to pawns and also the black
king is completely white in the open
white would be able to use this to his
advantage
however after Knight captures an F5 uh
King the F6 was played by shakar and now
there is a very specific set of moves
that allow anotherbeck to win the game
there's only one line that wins for him
so feel free to pause the video and try
to spot this incredible idea while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
White Queen can actually take the black
queen how you might ask well this is it
so congratulations to everyone who found
it and to those who just want to enjoy
the show it is Queen the G5 check and
now it doesn't matter where the black
king goes King to E6 and queen to E7
check this is what another big played
and it was in this position animal 47
that shahren mamidyar resigned in the
game as he realized that the best case
scenario he loses the queen on B1 uh
it's uh for example if you if you
capture the Knight then comes Queen
captures an F7 and now if you go to G4
then just Queen to F or check is
Checkmate if you go to E4 then Queen to
G6 with check King the E5 and now you
don't even have to capture the queen you
can deliver uh Pawn to F for checkmate
the queen covers all of these squares
the pawn covers D4 Queen covers d square
I mean nothing to do for the black king
so the your only move other than to go
G4 or E4 is to go E5 but now look at
this queen to E7 check and only one move
for the black king king to F5 and now
Queen to H5 with check and now okay
after King T5 you don't have a queen and
G6 so F4 will not be Checkmate but you
will settle for the black queen just
Queen captures on B1 uh and that that
would be it now we would have a queen
against the Knight of course completely
winning for for white but this is what
mom made out of missed when he played uh
this uh uh well uh not not optimal King
to F6 instead of King to f8 uh and uh
another bag just played it to Perfection
King he says Queen E7 check my major saw
the the the the it would end like this
and of course it was in this position
that Shakira mamidyar resigned the game
uh so yeah that's the game
um not only breaks his losing streak but
also destroys winning streak and he uh
throws mommy of the throne uh and he
wins uh his first game the only uh game
from day one of the Tata slindia Blitz
Edition uh if you are interested in the
standings as uh I don't know how many
more games we'll cover from day one uh
it is Arjun arigasi leading the uh rapid
tournament uh Blitz tournament as well
after winning the rapid tournament
absolutely spectacular and my major of
now in second place after he lost his
first game to abdusado he also lost the
video Gujarati in the in the next round
then with it with five and a half in
third place nihal uh in fourth place
Nakamura in fifth place maxulu in sixth
seventh uh in eight Wesley saw in ninth
and Abdul Saturn back in last place so
it's absolutely incredible uh not doing
spectacularly in Rapid as he is the
world rapid champion and now
uh having last place in Blitz I know
someone always has to be last it's just
the way the the standings work but I I
really don't know their back would uh uh
accomplish more here okay there's still
one more day a lot can happen but uh you
know maybe it's maybe it's the the
traveling but
it shouldn't really be uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it and
again uh special congratulations to
everyone who spotted this um a beautiful
idea of of winning the black queen not
an easy one to spot I would like to
thank Stefan trifonovich Andres
and Eric Adams for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up any wonderful
suggestions uh and the coverage of the
Tata still India Blitz Edition uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day